[Music]
somewhere when you were dreaming of
Claire all those years ago was it
because of my so-called life is that
where you first fell in love with her
maybe so-called life a little bit but
what else did you do I still can't wrap
my brain around the fact that showed
that darn good ended after one season
like we haven't made it all season it
didn't wasn't like Bowie said doesn't
matter who did it first matters it just
doesn't second and I think it was maybe
just a little too ahead of its time like
like Jim and his prophecies yeah he was
so different than what I mean was well I
think I was kind of radical to me to
have enough to be inside a teenage
girl's brain like that you know yeah and
now there's so many platforms that that
could survive even if only 10 people
watched it for a couple of years yeah it
was a very different environment the
land of Rome I don't know I'm still very
dear friends with Winnie Holtzman the
creator and then actually of many people
involved with the show so but I don't
know I probably not but I'm so grateful
that it's had this this afterlife that
it's had its really amazed especially
that it didn't do like a full season
like it is just reverberating yeah I
mean have you playing a complex teenager
back then or a concerned parent today
Claire Danes has been on our screens for
decades up next she stars alongside Jim
Parsons in a kid like Jake a drama that
navigates themes like parenting and
sexuality you're the one buying him
every princess DVD you can get your
hands on and this is freaking out when
people start to notice is it any wonder
he's confused I so recognized my own
experience in this story but but I say
you know Jim for example doesn't have a
child and he was as drawn to the
material as I so I don't think that it's
required to be a parent necessarily to
you to see yourself in historic we're
both in long-term relationships and as
natural and organic as I think I know
mine feels and I'm sure yours does to
you and it feels like well this is the
way it's supposed to be I always feel
very fortunate like what problems what
could we be presented with that would
really put us at a crossroads right you
know they say things like financial
stress and death and moves can all cause
that kind of thing in this case this how
we're raising this child and are we
doing right by him really puts them at a
at a loggerheads
[Music]
[Applause]